from the association of German chambers
of commerce and industry Franco taya
joins us now you head up the foreign
trade division of your association what
companies come to you or what advice do
companies seek from you on on something
like tax evasion the network of German
bilateral chambers abroad we are
supporting trait we want to facilitate
imports exports the building up of a
production in a specific country
building up of jobs there and at the end
of the day also the payment of Texas so
is it also offshore companies that you
deal with no I would suppose in general
generally not so we are supporting
companies of the so-called real economy
but as well don't neglect that company
they need to get access to finance and
therefore also banks but then we don't
speak about things like tax evasions or
tax havens tell me is well what are the
chances of change coming about from
these tax havens themselves and we need
it we need to change the text havens
they have built up a subversive business
model I would call call that that way in
order to get less dependent on tourism
and agriculture but the aim is not to
create welfare to create jobs in an
industrial sector it's only to influence
financial flows into islands just very
briefly one more question the block has
said the EU Tax Commissioner that the
block is very clear rules and very
strong standards on tax evasion of bank
secrecy do you agree then yes we have
rules but not all the countries are
respecting that rules we need
international agreements and enforcement
of the rules all over the world
you